Or three.
Two,
yes.
Alex Jones were alive.
Wow.
It's going to be back for the second visit.
It's good to be here man.
It's good to see ya.
We've got Trump meeting with Kim Jong.
I'm,
we've got the colon hearings in Congress.
A lot of energy going on.
Well,
a lot of things are happening.
Planets are aligned.
Uh,
we should tell everybody that you and I had with,
first of all,
we had a long conversation on the phone,
which led to just a lot of talk.
You were driving to Vegas a few weeks ago.
It's not like an hour and a half.
And then we decided to do another podcast and we cleared the air on the phone.
We decided to clear the air more on a podcast.
There's a lot of things going on.
Um,
I told you a long time ago that it would have you back on.
And uh,
in the interest of being completely honest,
there was,
I was hesitant to do it.
Not because I didn't want to talk to you,
but because of just the amount of bullshit that I get from people that get angry
that you and I are friends.
You know that.
Why give that guy a platform?
That's the big one.
That's the big one,
you know?
But you and I have always had a good time together.
We've always had fun together are only problems have always been when we're not
like if you're talking about me or if I'm talking about you,
not if we're talking to each other.
It's the distance has been the props to the telephone,
lack of communication.
The lack of communication has been the problem.
The thing that people are upset about you.
The thing that we wanted to talk about like quick to get it over with or not.
Not Quick,
but just to get it upfront.
That's the best way.
Misrepresentative yes.
Is the sandy hooks.
Yes.
Yeah.
So
your take on it,
just give me your take on it.
Well first off,
because it's always misrepresented.
I believe mass shootings happen and they're real tragedies and I believe
Parkland happened
and you believe Sandy Hook camp?
Absolutely,
and now just last year the media came out and said,
Alex Jones says Parkland didn't happen and he sending people to Parkland
parents' houses and there was no video.
No audio wasn't true.
I'd be,
like I said,
I believe Parklawn happened show.
I'm not going to be the mass shooting denial guy.
I have been branded as the sandy hook.
I've and imagine a final cut pro video editing timeline and you go back almost
seven years ago,
I guess it's more than seven years now,
and the Internet didn't believe some of the things about sandy hook.
I started covering it weeks after my first articles and things are all this will
be used for gun control and I bet the guys on Prozac and a mental patient,
which he was of course then about couple weeks into it,
my listeners and other starts sending me all these anomalies and things and
later turned out some of those anomalies weren't accurate and then I just moved
on from it.
Okay.
I mean,
I'm not Animal Lanza.
I didn't kill those kids,
but when I'm on the streets now,
people don't know who Adam Lanza is.
The guy that killed those kids,
they think it's me.
They say,
actually I believe you're not in prison for what you did to Sandy Hook.
All they know is Alex Jones,
Shani Hook dead kids show.
Well,
I don't think that's,
I think the majority of them are angry because the narrative has been that
you're sending people to the sandy hook families hopes homes.
Exactly,
and you'll never have the,
you're responsible for these people getting harassed because you said on your
radio show that it wasn't real.
Yes,
there is video and audio of me saying I can see out.
People don't think it happened and I can see how people think it's synthetic
users hers,
but stage events before that then gets edited,
put together,
cobbled together.
But I never said go to people's houses.
I never said go investigate you and to say that you think it's not real.
Yes,
I did,
but now you do think it's real because I learned some of the anomalies were not
accurate.
That's a problem with all this conspiracy shit.
Right,
because the conspiracy theory stuff,
the people that want to believe,
they believe in conspiracies with everything and I think there's a certain
percent,
and we talked about this just a few minutes ago.
Yeah.
When I started getting accused for years ago,
a couple years into it,
and I should know.
I think it happened
then people that I had interviewed and things you were just saying he's
involved.
He's one of them because you are now saying that it happened.
They thought that you had been compromised.
Yes,
and then I realized,
Oh,
this is how it works.
A certain percentage of people,
there's gets a phrenic.
Exactly,
and then they just think everything's a conspiracy.
This is the thing about conspiracies.
It's very attractive to people that are schizophrenia,
schizophrenia.
People think everything's a fucking conspiracy from top to bottom.
Every single interaction that people have is some sort of a stage event that's
trying to take them down or control this or mind control that.
That's a big factor in a lot of this conspiracy theory shit.
His mental illness.
When I started to have people come to the office Shang that I'm a Beau bridges
or that I'm Jeff Bridges or that I am your bill here.
They'll hitch and people in restaurant screaming,
Fq Bill.
We know it's you.
It's,
it's kind of like Dan rather than the guy threatening me,
I watch the signal.
Dan,
what's the [inaudible] what I've experienced now,
the quote fame of being super famous mean the conspiracy guy.
I was legitimately questioning things because of Gulf of Tonkin,
Northwoods things.
It really happened.
Babies that weren't thrown on incubators,
you're going to snack rack war,
but I kind of realized a few years ago that I kind of had my own mild psychosis
in that when you've been lied to by the media and the culture so much over and
over again,
everything,
then it starts becoming automatically.
You're sure it's fake and that everything you,
she fits into that.
This would probably you'll get four or five years ago I began to realize because
I was on the receiving end of people pulling up in white vans with guns at my
office.
Chang,
I know you put a microchip in my head and I'm gonna kill you.
And so it was kind of like,
once I got super famous,
it was like,
whoa.
There's a certain percentage of people that are way off on the spectrum where
they believe everything's fake.
And then there's people that believe everything they hear is true.
I mean,
you should be,
you should be questioning,
you should have the right to do it,
but,
but it's somewhere in the middle.
And so this one will say about Sandy Hook.
I legitimately questioned it when people brought up anomalies.
I then had debates about it on both sides.
The Internet pushed me to keep covering it.
I probably covered it 20 times in the first few years it happened.
And then as soon as I questioned it,
uh,
not being staged,
I got attacked so much that I said,
screw it.
Mass shootings happen.
I believe that happened.
But then media would call me or,
or interview me and say,
okay,
but tell us the anomalies of why you questioned.
They were getting me to say it again.
Not that I didn't have the right to question it,
but they thought,
well,
Alex Jones versus Ted kids,
Alex Jones denying an Alex Jones or asking families,
this is a perfect way to get this guy who so popular getting people to question
and getting people to think.
And so it took me years,
I think I'm smart.
I guess I'm not to figure out what's going on.
So when Hillary few months before the election,
it gives us huge speech and says,
Alex Jones as a dark heart,
uh,
he knows sandy hook kids died,
but he says they didn't and he sends people their houses.
He's the worst guy in the world.
So I came out and I said,
listen,
I never sent anybody to houses,
but I apologize.
It was taken out of context.
People have a right to question,
but I am sorry for the families and I'm sorry for your hurt and I get it.
And I've experienced crazy people now.
Big Time.
Just like you have,
please stop saying that.
I'm saying it didn't happen.
Please stop saying,
I'm sending people to houses because here's what happens when they put it on
every major TV channel,
local TV channels,
radio,
I mean,
I mean thousands of articles that then get syndicated.
I said 100,000 articles,
that's a low number.
The amount of sandy hook coverage against me has been selling stain.
It's so huge because it's supposed to be the first domino that once I'm taking
down all the dominoes fall.
Well,
it's also clickbait.
There's also a thing if you say Alex Jones,
Sandy Hook and you put in a title,
a certain amount of people,
we're just going to click on it.
Alex Jones is still pushing a sandy hook conspiracy theories one that I saw just
two days ago.
Exactly,
so,
so this is the point I've gotten to is here's the key.
They then they say more people are showing up in,
in Connecticut and more people are coming to their houses,
which they are because the media is all over the news saying there's a big
conspiracy here.
Alex Jones says it doesn't happen.
And so people then hear it and they think,
oh,
you know,
it's like looking for the moth man or something.
They're all running up there and the media saying it in my name and I'm saying,
no,
I believe it happened years ago.
And so then I'm getting the blame and the attacks and the demonization and the
threats for what the corporate media is saying over and over again that I'm
saying that it didn't happen.
And the families are getting the threats and the families are getting the
attacks and the families are getting called crisis actors.
Yes.
And then you can see for something different.
Oh my God.
In hindsight,
absolutely.
But again,
I legitimately didn't think my show was as powerful as it was show that I wasn't
retrospectively,
you know,
looking at everything I was doing as much as I should.
Nobody's perfect.
As you get older,
you grow when you learn things.
But I just began to realize about three years ago that they're making my
identity not being a national,
it's not being a populace,
not being a free market guy.
They're making my whole identity sandy hook.
And I didn't know they were gonna sue me then.
Well,
it's just because that's what gets clicks.
Yes.
But then,
but then before I ever got sued,
I said,
I believe Sandy Hook happened.
That should not mind at,
I barely ever covered.
It's stop.
Right?
But you understand that's not what they do doing.
They're not trying to make his weakness and made it even worse within not trying
to make your identity.
They're not trying to define you or do some sort of a documenter,
a biography,
and your life.
They're just finding something that people want to pay attention to.
This is one of the problems with,
with news coverage today is that they find things that people want to pay
attention to and they focus on them out of proportionate agree.
They say that I'm making money off sandy hook when when the newspapers and the
publishing houses are using me as a lay to put out that had Shinier,
very hurtful thing.
Awesome to be hurtful.
I didn't mean to be in senior year.
I was legitimately questioning because the Internet was,
and actually get a bunch of other stage stuff and then I say,
hey,
take it back.
Don't do it.
And they go,
no,
we're going to commit this hurtful thing that's chill free speech.
But it's hurtful in your fricking name.
And then,
and then that's why,
and I'm not saying I'm the victim here,
I'm saying stop it because everything they do about the platform,
I me,
the biggest frustration is I still have my huge audience and radio stations and
you'll infowars.com and [inaudible] dot com but reaching new people's very hard.
And then now that I've been silenced,
the mainstream media can say whatever they want,
Joe,
about you,
about me.
And I can't respond.
I mean,
you can go to Youtube and type in Alex Jones.
Well this is where you'll notice the negative stuff.
And there's one that says white supremacy and Alex Jones and you click on it.
It's a famous British actor and author saying,
Alex Jones says,
kill the a of families of,
of Parkland parents.
And I'm actually having lawyers getting ready to fall suit over this.
I warn the guy shouldn't let her,
she didn't take it.
Now I have to,
you could pull up this famous British actor,
I forget,
I forget his name.
He can pull up.
You just type in Alex Jones that youtube,
all the main stuff's put up on top.
It's like the seventh eighth link and it says Alex Jones and white supremacy
what to do about it.
And he says,
Alex Jones and the lights of premise are saying,
go to the people's houses at Parkland and kill the parents and we have to take
him off the air because he says,
kill the parents.
There's no free speech for killing parents.
And I'm like,
dude,
do not say that I'm going to get killed.
I mean,
I am never said nobody died.
It Parkman and I sure as hell didn't say kill their parents.
Let's,
let's chill now.
Can you talk about fake news?
They have green lighted making,
anything you can imagine up about me.
And,
and it's like insane.
And that's all I'm saying is,
is that at a certain point it's like Jesus,
again,
let's,
let's take this step by step.
I'm sorry I'm writing this and this.
We want to give you an opportunity to communicate and clear the air and talk and
some of the shit that you and I talked about earlier.
Um,
there's a bunch of things going on.
One,
there's,
it's a story that attracts people's attention,
right?
A story of a guy who sang that people didn't get killed when they did get
killed.
And it's horrific for people to,
to look at.
It's terrific to people to think about that their own children who not only get
murdered,
but then someone would accuse them of being a crisis actor.
So then they start pushing that story and that story becomes something that they
make money off of,
which is really in,
in some ways kind of ironic.
They keep this story in the news and they keep getting clicks off of you and
misrepresenting some of the things that you've said yes.
And,
and some of the things that you said you wish you hadn't said,
that's,
that's also real.
But,
but I mean let's be clear,
I'm not even defending my shelf.
People learn stuff.
As you get older.
Hindsight,
you're like,
why did I do that?
Like I used to whatever was the big hot thing on the Internet.
I would just debate it cause it was interesting.
But this is what I wanted to get to you.
You were doing this show and in this show you're on the air hours and hours a
day and you're ranting about all these various things.
Is,
is,
is it fair to say that you weren't really 100% aware of what kind of influence
you were having?
Absolutely.
If you did know,
you would have phrase things differently and done things differently.
You know it's,
it's even beyond that.
I was just younger and,
and I was covering what other people were saying.
I was not the first the 10th or a hundredth,
the 10000th you're reading about it on the Internet was a firestorm all over the
news that people are denying it.
And I've got producers going,
hey look at this video.
But isn't that the problem with every single national tragedy?
Anytime something happens,
there's a certain amount of people that think that there's a conspiracy,
even when it's just a plane crash,
even when it's just what it fill in the blanks.
Any sort of national,
actually at an all,
I'm shaking ish,
Shandy hooking up the hill on dying on I,
I support people's right to question and I understand because there's been so
much lying and corporate media and by governments and,
and,
and staged events that are admitted,
the classified that once people see that one thing was staged than everything
else must be stage.
And then I have been on the receiving end of literally thousands of made up
conspiracies,
which you'll laugh at until people on a truckload gun show up.
Yeah.